today was so good
I didn't realise how much it being out of our routine was affecting us
until today when we got back into it
we were all happy and had more patience with each other
and our day just felt really productive
the kids jumped right back into lessons as if we haven't taken a four week break
I was actually really impressed with how much they retained
I was expecting need to do a few weeks of review
but they are ready to move full speed ahead
I don't know if it's because we supplemented with learning apps
the last couple of weeks or they're getting older and ready to move faster
either way they haven't skipped
in fact I actually think we can skip a few lessons and get back on track
not that my goal is to finish the curriculum by the end of the year
but I think they're ready for a little bit of a challenge
so I think I'm gonna spend less time reviewing and more just moving ahead
the beauty of homeschooling is I can slow down and speed up as I need to
and right now
I think all of the unschooling we've done the last couple of weeks
have put them a little bit further ahead